he and bucky brooks have a muslin
podcast the move that sticks podcast
move the sticks is his twitter handle
and i love this guy and i cannot wait to
keep talking to him over and over again
to her at the combine but that means the
season will go too fast
and he is daniel jeremiah back here on
the rich island show how are you dj
i'm doing great rich i prefer not to
talk about baseball today let's keep it
strictly football that's okay uh we
could talk american league baseball
certainly since my yankees are right on
the trail of the uh red sox of
brockman's in their play too today and a
little day night double header by the
end of the day
sun sets tonight uh yankees could
actually
have caught up and potentially even
gotten past the boston red sox and they
lost column today so i'm happy to talk
about american league baseball if you
don't yeah i i could i can do some
american league stuff um and by the way
any of your listeners uh can can throw
the baseball more than 85 miles per hour
we could use you uh right now because we
are a little white in the pitching
department
david weather's kid not getting it done
anymore huh so yeah he's had a rough
stretch here a little bit of a rough
stretch padre fan daniel jeremiah here
on the rich eisen show um okay so which
uh give me a standout performance from
uh preseason weekend number one that you
think is actually an indicative
and a uh bright shining light here uh
for for somebody give me something for
you yeah i'm gonna go let's let's uh
let's go through the rookie quarterbacks
rich go forward and uh i what i did is i
went through and watched all the tape of
the five uh rookie quarterbacks and i uh
i took all my notes but then i tried to
for simplicity purposes here just to
narrow it down to two words so like the
takeaway and two words from each of the
quarterbacks um so we start with trevor
lawrence the two words i wrote down were
just clock adjustment
like that's you know all the abilities
there you see the touch you see the arm
strength on on some of the out throws
but to me he's good he's
among all the quarterbacks you watch
these rookies
he's got to adjust his clock and speed
it up a little bit it just to me it was
a tick slow
with how he was operating some of the
pocket stuff he he wasn't super
comfortable in there that's going to
come with just more reps under duress
which he did not get a lot of clemson
but uh that to me is going to be the big
adjustment for him is clock adjustment
well i mean it's better happen faster he
might not be named the starter daniel
you know don't think yeah
i like his chances i do like his channel
chances too yeah all right so
matriculate your way down your list if
you don't mind yeah let's go to wilson
um
to me rich
i just wrote down smooth operator
everything was just very smooth and
poised and comfortable um get got his
feet in the ground delivered the ball
accurately knew where to go with the
football a couple plays you know they're
missing some linemen a couple of them
the pockets collapsing on him he gets
the ball out to where it needs to be uh
some big third downs and there was no
razzle dazzle
plays you know that's what you kind of
was fun watching him at byu was all the
creative stuff this was simply just just
operate the play and uh and did it in
very smooth and efficient manner so um i
thought you know for some of the stuff
that you read come out of camp and this
that or the other he got out there in a
preseason game i know it's not the
starters uh but with the with the kind
of the live bullets around him i thought
his his his pulse and heart rate was
very low
okay so was that a shade reference is
that what you're saying for zach wilson
uh yes i i did i could i i could uh
carry that tune but i'm a little bit
that nasal right now i don't think no
worries no worries by the way i think i
did i got an odd out of you i got a knot
out of you tj jefferson right didn't
expect that one coming certainly in
reference to zach wilson cut me out of
that uh okay uh now i guess move on to
trey lance if we want to go from um
to trey lance although i almost wanted
to go coast to coast later chicago go
straight to field
ladies
standing up for that one yeah
well done
by the way
i mean you talk about the ball coming
off somebody's hand i mean that it was
juicy um just just how much force and
velocity he has the throwback touchdown
everybody saw that 80 yard throw there
are some other balls you know on the
move and in the pocket the ball just
jumps out of his hand i mean he has got
a huge arm um so raw power is what i
wrote on there because there is the raw
part of it he held the ball a little bit
the offensive line he was playing behind
was not good um and that chief's
defensive line got after him a little
bit so um
there's times you get the ball in your
hand throw it in completion you know
avoid the sack i get that stuff he's
going to get better and better
as that goes along but man
with him and i'll get the fields in a
second the thing that was exciting
no design quarterback runs like that's a
whole that's a whole other universe that
they aren't even tapping into in these
preseason games they're just letting
these kids play from the pocket then
they're they're booting them and letting
them get outside and make some plays but
like they haven't even tapped into this
whole other realm of offense that
they're going to be able to use with
design quarterback run game so that's
what's so exciting about both those guys
um but with trey lance yeah there's some
touch he can improve on some touch and
some intermediate stuff he's going to
colleen wolfe needs to stay far away
from treylands because if kurt warner
broke one of her fingers trey lance
might break her whole hand
that's pretty wild man i know there's an
interesting moment on on our on our
network so
uh just pausing in this the fact that
you're not seeing the boots and the run
from the quarterback from those play
calls that's purposeful because you want
to see these guys just do the basics and
get their footwork and or or are they
just trying to hide it because that
stuff's coming for somebody that might
start week one like what what
you know i i don't think you want to
give away carries for free you know so
in other words i'm not going to have my
quarterback take punishment for in a
game it doesn't matter right so i'm not
going to get i'm not going to call you
know a quarterback power or you know
according to your quarterback read down
the red zone let him you know run and
take punishment he's not going to do
that in in this setting so that's what
is going to give defenses a whole lot
more to think about uh once you start
incorporating that so they've moved the
pocket i mean there were some boots and
waggles and things like that but they
didn't um you know there was no
quarterback power called both these guys
did a lot of that in college and i'm
sure it will be part of what they do in
the nfl and then daniel jeremiah here on
the rich eisen show justin fields his
performance um you know when he got in
against the dolphins was uh clearly the
one that that got much of the attention
because of you know his performance as
well as the team that he's performing
for that's been desperate for a
quarterback of his apparent caliber what
do you make of his
performance
the two words i summed up were poison
play-making
i thought you know and all the almost
all these guys
he just it was just very relaxing very
calm but then he mixed in just to play
making ability pocket breaks down he's
out the back door he's running for a
touchdown
what would be scrambles for you know
three to five to six yards for
quarterbacks he turns into 21 22-yard
gains you know the touchdown don't i
don't put too much into the touchdown i
was a schemed winner on the on the throw
to the tight end who was completely
naked um so you know but he made a nice
show there but he threw a corner out
that was dropped earlier on in the game
that was probably probably the best uh
just pure throw in pocket throw with
many of the quarterbacks for the for the
week it was just beautiful and the guy
didn't didn't bring it down so
poison play-making no it's not perfect i
think some some have you know made it
sound like this was just most
unbelievable performance you've ever
seen he did fumble the ball he had a
ball that probably should have been
picked off but overall again poise and
play making rich i mean this is uh
it's not it's not big for him it did not
look big for him at all daniel jeremiah
here on the rich eisen show walking
through the uh first preseason week
assessment of the
first round drafted quarterbacks that
leaves us with mack jones in new england
would you see what you write down for
him
yeah i wrote down completion collector
like that's that's how he plays that's
who he is i don't think that mac jones
translates to all 32 teams you know i
think he was going to be very dependent
on where he went and how they used him
and i don't know that you could hand
pick a better spot for him than new
england they're going to run the ball a
lot
they're going to get the ball out of his
hands quickly whether that's off play
action then get your foot in the ground
make a quick decision get the ball out
or they did some empty um get back there
and just let him diagnose c and get the
ball out of his hand he did not have wow
arm strength he's not going to overpower
you with these big time power throws but
he's get he makes good decisions he
showed good touch and he's just gonna
he's just gonna rack up a bunch of
completions and that's that's you know
formula for how they're going to play in
new england so kind of look at the
broader sense of you know him versus cam
this team is kind of designed to play
with a guy like mac jones i mean he fits
them better than cam does
um i think they're going to be able to
run the ball they have an offensive line
that's built to run it you're going to
see a lot of two backs a lot of two
tight ends and they're going to run run
run and then they're going to they want
somebody to make good efficient
decisions and and throw the ball
accurately and that's that's really who
he is and also you could also say that
they're a perfect fit for him because
whatever belichick might be throwing at
him we don't know
it can't be any different than what
sabin threw at him
right i mean
honestly like that though his his skin
must be already so saban thick
that whatever belichick might be
coaching him hard or tough love or
anything like that it can't be anything
he's never seen before you know right no
i i would say the only difference uh
from those two coaches maybe the volume
i think nick might give you a little
more volume um with the discussion
whereas belichick might be a little bit
understated
i don't know what's scarier
you know i don't know what could be
scarier to a kid but all right so
putting it all together
yeah uh can can we make a a a guess
a good guess uh an educated guess
what week one status for everyone's
gonna be regular season after week one
status preseason or no
daniel no i mean look it's still it's
it's a long way to go and the preseason
games why i enjoy watching them and it's
fun and getting to watch tape again for
you know fresh tape for the new year
right i think what's happening on the
practice field especially these joint
practices you know trey lance this is a
big week for him they have joint
practices with chargers so i'm going to
go up there on friday and watch those
guys work together because you're going
to get to see a different defense you're
going to play against a lot of the
regulars uh in an environment where
you're protected he's not going to get
hit but he can see different looks
different defenses with really good
talent on the other side so that'll be
really uh important in his development
and kind of let them know where he
stands in this in this process so i know
mac mac jones they've been doing joint
practice with the eagles um so we won't
be privy to all those uh the video for
all that stuff but that you could say is
maybe even more important than what
we're seeing these pre-season games
daniel jeremiah here on the rich eisen
show and i guess we'll have you back on
and revisit that subject once we get
closer to the regular season for the
moment though who are we sleeping on you
got an under the radar team for me
because uh you know
i i i usually not usually every year i
pick one in either
either
conference um and i'm formulating and
i'll be honest i'm probing what your
thoughts are on that subject matter
well i think i'm going to retire the
cardinals i think they've been that team
for me in the last seven years
that broken clock is going to be right
soon man i'll tell you that you know
yeah so i'm telling you yeah they they
have hung their jersey up in the rafters
they're in the hall of fame of my uh my
early breakout team pick but you know
what
i call the charger games i know and i'm
not going to say the chargers but you
know if they're healthy they're going to
be they're going to be good that's been
the story with this team for a while
right just stay healthy but i look
inside that division and a team i don't
know what people are talking about but
if you watch them
against the minnesota vikings the denver
broncos rich that is first of all the
defense with vic fangio and all the
horses they have on defense and you saw
patrick certain with a pick six uh you
know they're going to be good on defense
but to me that wasn't the story when you
watch that offense and you see a track
team out there i mean kj hamler can fly
he's another year in in in the nfl he's
more comfortable and you're gonna see
good things for him jerry judy and year
two you're gonna get cortland sutton
back throw him in the mix you've got two
tight ends that run 4-4
so to me that that is a chance to be a
dynamic offense of vertical offense lots
of big plays and a defense that if you
can give them a lead they can rush the
quarterback and they can turn the ball
over as well so um i think that's a
fascinating division i think the raiders
will be better i think the chargers
definitely be better and you've got the
best you know the most talented team
with the best player in the league
patrick holmes in kansas city so uh that
that's going to be a fun one and i think
denver broncos that would be my team
don't sleep on them dj i'm i'm i'm loath
to agree with you because i named the
denver broncos the sleeper team and the
afc my sleeper team in the afc in 2020
on this show and hours later von miller
hurt his foot
so he might do that that actually
happened my sleeper pick actually got
buried
that never woke up um as soon as i named
it uh i'm gonna should i bounce my nfc
team i'm thinking off of dj right now
okay i'm gonna do it what about the
carolina panthers as a sleeper team for
2021 in the nfc
another team with a lot of speed which i
love right you know i i haven't seen any
of sam i didn't see sam the other night
i'm i'm curious i haven't really heard
much of how he's doing down there i'm
excited to see him we both love him as a
guy hoping that that all works out for
him there but to me that would be kind
of as sam goes so go to the carolina
panthers really because i i kind of like
their defense and and and we are truly
all sleeping on
on year two of matt rule and
joe brady's passing game you know what i
mean like exactly and and and then the
division we all know has the defending
super bowl champions in it but i i'm
wondering what you make of the saints
right now i've got cam jordan coming up
next hour
and you know michael thomas out for a
while there was a back and forth
like
michael thomas is you know battling alan
robinson for the most passive aggressive
social media posts against his team you
know in terms of
dynamic uh top wide receivers it is
right now so uh uh and then of course
the quarterback spot post breeze
what do you make of that conversation
with the saints daniel jeremy well rich
i don't know and and i i peg probably
del tufo for more of a donut guy than
either you were brockman very good um um
i don't know if you are like are you a
plain donut guy are you a sprinkle donut
guy well uh dj i'm going to go off the
board here i'm more of a jelly doughnut
guy which doesn't have the hole in it
which might actually poke a hole in
where you're going with your analogy
totally yeah totally going to ruin the
analogy pretend that you said you like
sprinkles yes let's do that then i i you
can have a james donut
would pay some sprinkles or you can have
a plain taste donut like i'd i'd rather
have the james donut with some tasting
sprinkles to me that's just that gives
you two it's a two-for-one special
the problem is is a is a doughnut has is
the number zero um
dj and hopefully that's zero turnovers
well well we've got to stick with that
oh yeah keep the bakery theme going here
um so no i i understand that but put it
all together and and i'm i'm genuinely
concerned about the saints viability
this year i'm beginning to get that
feeling um and i don't know
you know i i i
i eventually land on i trust sean payton
to make it right
but um again i'll just leave the florida
you want to play that here's here's a
game for you okay if you played the if
you played the bubble wrap game like you
needed one player to be put in bubble
wrap to guarantee that he does not get
hurt or you're in big trouble alvin
kamara is the bubble wrap guy like if
anything happens to him this all of a
sudden is an under 500 football team i
mean that there's they don't have any
weapons
so
that to me is he is going to be
force-fed and he is going to have to
have a monster year to help kind of
carry this offensive load because it's
uh there's not a lot of playmakers when
you look around outside of him you just
can't give any idea i think we're going
to have to do this we have a segment
open later on in the show let's do
five bubble wrap guys in the nfl
alvin kamara is one of them no question
about it because without him right
that's the general sense although you do
never know who might be you know under
wraps that that sean payton will
unveil but that is definitely something
to think about all right well have a
good time up there with shanahan and the
hall of famer lynch and everybody up
there and let's connect over the next
couple weeks and get your thoughts right
before the season if you don't mind i
appreciate you great guys catch up
richard you got it right back at you
moving the sticks podcast with bucky
brooks daniel jeremiah move the sticks
on twitter and instagram hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here